bonjour antoine bucarest a annoncé
l'expulsion hier d'un diplomate russe
sans soutien la république tchèque est
le dernier d'une longue série queer
l'effet dernièrement le métier de
diplomate paraît être bien précaire
temps depuis quelques semaines on
assiste à une véritable valse des
diplomates entre la russie l'union
européenne mais aussi les états unis les
américains sont d'ailleurs coutumier du
fait des expulsions de diplomates ont eu
lieu du temps d'obama de trump et même
depuis l'arrivée de joe biden il ya une
dizaine de jours encore pour des
soupçons d'ingérence et des accusations
de cyberattaques londres il ya eu aussi
largement recours dans le cadre de la
sphère skripal
mais au sein de l'union européenne
s'étaient jusque maintenant moins
courant mais depuis la décision de
chèques de renvoyer 18 représentants
russes le mouvement s'est accéléré et
prague accuse en effet moscou d'être
responsables de l'explosion d'un dépôt
de munitions en 2014 dans laquelle deux
personnes avaient trouvé la mort ce sont
donc 18 diplomates russes qui ont été
priés de rentrer à la maison
imité par 20 de leurs homologues
tchèques dans le sens inverse depuis par
solidarité avec prague l'estonie la
lettonie la lituanie la slovaquie est
donc la roumanie le dernier en date ont
fait de même
et cet effet domino résulte en une
détérioration des relations entre la
russie et les pays concernés
vladimir poutine dans une conversation
téléphonique avec eminem a cru y asseoir
à d'ailleurs expliqué à d'ailleurs
qualifié d'absurdes les accusations de
prague et leurs conséquences
et même s'il ya des expulsions il y en a
toujours eu des expulsions de diplomates
depuis aussi longtemps que la diplomatie
existe il semble que ce soit devenu la
dernière mesure à la mode pour afficher
son mécontentement envers la russie
et ce n'est sans doute pas terminée
merci beaucoup antoine gayraud pour
toutes ces précisions antoine claireaux
notre correspondant à moscou